nos encontramos en el frente de la línea
de domestia díptica uno de los frentes
junto con backmud más
importantes y más difíciles para el
ejército ucraniano en esta región de
donest la ciudad de está siendo atacada
desde hace meses por las tropas rusas
Allí se viven fuertes enfrentamientos
incluso aquí los hombres que pelean en
este sector los llaman una segunda
bacmut y es que si bien los ojos del
mundo los últimos meses han estado en la
población de bacmut que tenía 80.000
habitantes y que ha sido escena tal vez
de las batallas más intensas de esta
guerra la situación no es muy difícil no
es diferente en abdica una población más
pequeña de 30.000 habitantes y que se ha
convertido en un objetivo para las
fuerzas de Moscú porque también esta
línea protege la defensa de lo que son
grandes ciudades detrás Y también luego
más adelante la ciudad de Nitro cuando
se les pregunta aquí que hay algún
movimiento sobre esa contraofensiva que
planea el ejército ucraniano en las
próximas semanas Ellos dicen que no ven
ningún refuerzo de tropas que aquí ya la
batalla es supremamente intensa y que
más bien lo que ellos hacen es
fortalecerse para defender esa línea de
defensa desde que estamos aquí Hace un
par de horas no hemos sido sentido como
entra y sale artillería o diferentes
otro tipo de ataques en este momento
hace poco unos minutos cayeron varios
gratis a pocos metros de aquí incluso
donde nos encontrábamos con las tropas
ucranianas nos pidieron que saliéramos
porque estaban atacando y a uno de los
hombres que defendían a pocos metros la
línea de frente había fallecido Así que
la situación es bastante difícil Ucrania
decía ayer que había ganado unos metros
en abdica pero aquí nos dicen que si
bien es cierto Esto no es totalmente una
batalla y una y una victoria concreta
que la situación cambia permanentemente
en este frente